I come home and uh
my wife's car is not there it's like 11
30 at night
no lights are on in the house and we
always left the light on if I'm out and
um
walked in
I have a man who stretched out on my
floor
I checked him and he was dead
and I could see he was dead under no
way that I could see was I not going to
jail
[Music]
I was born in anken on the Isle of Man
um 1954 a few uh weeks after I was
baptized my mother left me in my
grandmother's doorstep and she left
never to return to the aisle my
grandparents made plans with the the
church on the aisle the Catholic Church
to have me sent away I was sent away to
Ottawa Canada in August of 54. to a
place called the St Joseph's orphan
Asylum ran by the great nuns of the
Cross which I always tell people sounds
warm and fuzzy I'm sure but
I was only there about six or eight
months it turned out that the girl who
took me to Canada had worked for my
grandmother named Martha Virginia
Boswell who was one of the Boswell
gypsies that used to come to the Isle of
Man she saw that my future there might
not be good she took me illegally and
took me into the U.S eventually we ended
up going down the Seabourn communities
and landing in Phoenix Arizona
and um
she had my grand my mother had given her
my her passport to tell me in case I
ever wanted to find her it was like a
cookie crumb but she had taken my mom's
picture out put her picture in so she
used my mother's name
so I was raised under my birth name I
believe she was my birth mother I called
her I called her mom
um she was the one that had told me all
about my being from the Isle of Man and
funny enough all throughout my life all
I could think about was getting back
home at some point unfortunately due to
bad relationships and uh the problem
that she had she had drinking issues
that
um
she got real sick and when because of
some of the people she worked with well
to do one particular family called the
wet Morse
um they had adopted a boy and a girl
and they had plans to move because Dr
Wetmore had just gotten his degree and
he was going to be teaching at the
University
and something happened to the boy and
the boy was 12 years old even though I
was 14 I was small because I'm
malnutrition
um and um
I could actually fit into a 12 year
old's clothes and stuff so he told her
he would give me a good life and adopt
me and stuff like that and he said that
he paid her to take my custody
and um I was given that child's identity
his name his date of birth his social
security number all the things that you
need to be a person
and um
nobody knows what happened to that child
even the the US government had looked
and could not find any evidence of that
child after I took his identity
so
yeah but Dr Wetmore was unique in his
own ways him and I we he used to try to
beat me and things and that's kind of
believed to what may have happened to
the other Childs he may have done it and
the other boy may not survive the
biggest difference between me and him
was because
I grew up with this idea that I was
something special through Martha because
one of the things she'd always told me
to remember was I was a man of the aisle
Son Of The Sea and the brother of the
storm and I could weather anything
because the storm around me is my
brother so I can weather anything
um one particular incident it was really
the last time he did a beating was that
he beat me with a belt while he had me
hold a tree out in the back and he beat
me on my legs and my lower back and
stuff and I wouldn't shed a tear for him
and when he was done I turned and said
is that the best you got and he backed
away and went inside and stared at me he
was used to Breaking men in his uh
uh way of business and and stuff so he
was having a problem with this this
child that could stand up to him and no
matter what I wasn't afraid of him and
that was something that scared him more
than anything else I signed up for the
United States Navy
um
is I had a lot of friends going in the
Marine Corps at the time because I was
still rather small I didn't think I
could make him or being a be a marine I
didn't think I was big enough yeah but
the other side of the coin I didn't want
to hurt people so I decided to enlist as
a Navy corpsman which is a medical Corps
I was your
um like state of mind off that did you
see anything that particularly affected
you or or stuck with you well just the
fact that if if anybody really thinks
about the Vietnam era uh vets that were
in that time Vietnam was not a popular
um politically popular
um
engagement you most people wouldn't even
say they were were Vietnam Vets they
they we or they would or they went to
hide some hid in the streets as homeless
and drunks and drug addicts some went
into the woods some went to Canada some
went down to the jungles of South
America
because you just couldn't fit in in
places like that
I hid in the world of motorcycles I
prefer to be around motorcycles to
people because
I learned with people if you say one
wrong thing
the relationship can be ruined forever
yeah so
my personal relationships with people
uh were never very good so in Halloween
in 1977
um my wife my first wife had abandoned
me my son when he was nine months old I
had my son until 1978 and then my ex my
my first wife she had decided her
parents her parents decided we should
get divorced and she should get my son
even though she didn't want my son she
didn't want to be a mom
um Dr Wetmore had contacted me and said
look
I want your son I'll give him the proper
life that you didn't want I'll raise him
to be a doctor or a lawyer but I
wouldn't do it in a fit of anger he
threw an envelope at me and it had my my
what my mom's passport and I had my
baptism certificate for the Isle of Man
and uh told me you're not an American
you're not my son get out of here I
never want to see you again and then he
switched sides and he made sure my ex
got my son I met the other girl my my
second wife through a friend's mind uh
she was related to and uh
I started
getting my life back together we had a
son
and I just I thought maybe it's time for
me to find go back to the aisle now I've
got proof that I'm from there
uh so I was going to get a passport to
go back and try to find my family I
didn't know if my family is alive or
dead or you know who was who was there
or whatever but I I felt this calling
that I needed to go back
and I told my wife this is what I want
to do and she kept saying no I don't
think it's a good idea I don't think
that's a good idea
and I told her look it's not like I'm
moving over there I'm just going to go
over for a trip
and I was going to go by myself because
I didn't want her to come with me in
case everything went terribly wrong you
know and uh anyway come to find out
years later that she had actually uh
been telling Dr Wetmore things I was
doing
and Dr Wetmore realized that if I did go
get a passport he would be likely in
trouble because they would ask Where'd I
come from I don't have a birth
certificate
I'm using this other kid's name but at
this time I was starting to take back my
birth name with that once I had the
passport
um
so he realized he might be in prom
at which point in time he sat and play a
number of other situations that came
about
that would eventually lead me to prison
1983 obviously that was a day that
probably changed the course of your life
forever actually it was December of 82 I
had met a girl named Jackie who had been
Martha's youngest daughter and I thought
my half-sister because I thought Martha
was my mom
and her uncle her dad's brother who has
been caring for a guy named Stanley John
Kearns
and then she had a son named Danny and
they were living in LA and they wanted
to move up to be around me so I helped
him move up in the six months they were
there from December till June it was
just got terribly terribly wrong uh John
and I got into one argument after
another uh he used to come down my bike
shop and try to tell me tell me and my
crew how to do things
uh
a few times he was drunk and he pulled
knives I'd get an altercation when I
used to put him in choke holes to make
him subdued and stuff and though police
had gotten called because neither of us
pressed charges and they weren't there
when the cryings were happening we never
got neither of us got arrested but it
was in the history they the police
reports so there was a history of this
um
so in June of 83
I was out of town he got into an
altercation with Jackie and uh started
choking her son and my wife and Jackie
at that time took both of them to pull
his hands off the boy
and then the following day or so he was
driving the car and he started punching
Jackie and she stopped the car and ran
into uh the Marjorie Mason uh Women's
Center I come back I'm found he's
arrested I tell my wife under no
circumstances he'd come to house you
know we've got a young son I don't want
you to have to put up with him you know
uh I said if he does get out of jail
whatever don't let him in it's about
about a month later
um
I come home and uh
my wife's car is not there it's like 11
30 at night
no lights are on in the house and we
always left the light on if I'm out and
um
walked in
I have a man who stretched out on my
floor
and like I said having been a corpsman
having been a you know medical Corps
I checked him and he was dead
and I could see he was dead yet there
were no wounds
um
a lot of people said oh why didn't you
call the police and my response has
always been
here's a man I have a history of
fighting with
I'm a biker and at that time I was with
a motorcycle club saw as a patch holder
under no
way that I could see was I not going to
jail
my first thought was I have to secure my
home I have to get him away from my home
no matter what else I do I didn't call
anybody
I just went and got a sleep bag put him
in the sleeping bag and was and was
putting him in the back of my truck when
my wife suddenly drove up and it's
probably about
maybe 12 30 now or so
and uh my wife jumps out of the car and
says yeah he came over uh I gave him
dinner and then I gave him his asthma
capsules that I've had and uh I said you
weren't supposed to have let him in oh
but but he was agitated and I didn't I
didn't want him to do anything with the
babies here
and she said that after he collapsed she
got frightened and she went to a
friend's house
and she's been there and then she
finally figured out she'd come home in
case I was home and uh she knew I would
be able to figure out what to do
and we start driving I have no idea
where I'm going
I don't really know what I'm going to do
I just have to get them away from the
house
[Music]
but then for the next four four and a
half hours she's harping on me about you
you're stupid you didn't bring a shovel
what are you going to do the body are
you going to bury it are you going to
burn it are you what are you going to do
it where are you going to dump it what
are you going to do for four and a half
hours is I'm trying to drive and trying
to think I've got this harping in my ear
and next thing I know I see false Dawn
starting and we were driving down a
rural road where a lot of Farm Workers
would be coming to work soon
and I just pulled over and I took his
body out and I set him up against a post
right off the road where he'd be easily
found because again it wasn't one of
these things where I was trying to hide
the body I just wanted it away from my
house it couldn't be found at my house
and then
and this will be always one of the
things people will say one of the
stupidest things I did and I'm not going
to disagree
figuring he just got out of jail I
didn't figure
he would have identifications and stuff
with him so I took out a piece of paper
and pencil and I wrote in case of
emergency call and I put my name and
phone number and I stuck it in his
wallet
and I left that and we drove away
so it was about three days later and the
police called and said they'd found his
body and they asked me when was the last
time you saw Stanley alive
and um I told him about a month ago
maybe you know at least three three few
weeks to a month and so everything
should be okay except for
the moment that they also had contacted
Jackie because she had been the victim
in the reason he was in jail
and told him that he'd been he found
dead
she immediately grabbed some of his
checks because she he'd lived at her
place and got with my wife and they went
down and they cashed checks on his bank
account to get back what she said was
the money he had taken from her from her
welfare or what they would call the Dole
over here
[Music]
um
but this is three days after he's been
found dead and of course the banks have
been notified
and they're going in there with the
checks signed by him it was just about
30 days from the time they'd found the
body that they came and arrested my wife
and uh and Jackie and uh
I
found out that they had been arrested
the initial coroners reported come back
for death by strangulation
and uh
though there was no evidence the fact
that the history was there that I had
choked him out and because I was you
know physically capable of being able to
do that
it immediately turned to the fact they
thought I did it but they had no
evidence they went to Jackie and told
her they were she was facing 18 years
for forged checks when they told her she
was going to face possibly 18 years
she said let let me tell you what that
happened and they went tell us what and
says well I want immunity
and the D.A said okay and said uh well
here's what really happened
Sandy uh his wife
poisoned the man
and then he helped her get rid of the
body
and when they said poison
they went what do you mean he was
strangled he said no he was poisoned
they went back did coroners report
Corners uh inquest thing again and sure
enough potassium cyanide have been but
had killed him they now charged my wife
with murder one with two counts of
special circumstances each one carries
the death penalty one for uh the
poisoning and one for getting monetary
gain because apparently Jackie had given
her a little bit of money on the side
too they stopped even bothering with me
except that every couple weeks they keep
changing my charges around accessory
conspiracy uh all this stuff lying to
the police which was their favorite one
they tried my wife in December
Jackie was their primary Witness
um
the jury came back eleven to one to
convict my wife on murder one with
special circumstances
but they didn't have a
a complete jury so they had a hung jury
so the D.A came to me
and said look we're gonna we lost this
bite this much so we're going to do it
again and I'm going to make sure that we
don't have any moral you know problems
on the jury
unless you you want to take this deal
I'm going to offer you I'm off here one
time and one time only deal
and my what my attorney was sitting
there
my wife's attorney was sitting there and
D.A was sitting there and he said we
feel you're responsible for whatever
happens there so here's the deal we'll
offer you a 13-year prison sentence
and he goes uh now you have 10 minutes
to make a decision think about this
are you going to be able to tell your
son that you allowed his mom to be put
to death because you would not step up
for her yeah oh by the way you got five
minutes left
um
who do you think could do better time in
prison you veteran
biker or your wife who's just a
housewife and a mom oh and I'll sweeten
the deal I will never personally oppose
any parole for you and her attorney said
you know this is the best we can get
so I took it
I would do 13 years so my wife would be
released from all of her charges
and given to my son my wife got released
two weeks after I took the deal
and because she'd been in the county
jail for like six months with these
other girls one of them introduced her
to her brother and a few weeks after she
got out she was gone I took my son and
left the state with uh this other guy
the way the sentence had been is I was
getting 13 years
if I stayed out of trouble worked good
time all that but what started the
downfall on that was
about three years after I went in
uh the California legislature changed
the law took all the good time and
worked time away from
uh life-term inmates
well now I can't do half time because
now they just took it all the way so now
now I'm looking at 27 to life
I did half my life and two-thirds of my
adult life in prison you could have
three stabbings during your yard time
before they'd finally close the yards
make it go back to cells because they
would just shut the art they'd put
everybody on the ground come out pick up
the body take the body away and resume
yard
but after the third time they go that's
enough okay everybody go back to
yourselves play time's over and he goes
don't you know who I am I'm Charles
Manson I'm more famous than Jesus Christ
and I'm like yeah okay I went to court
and was transferred to clung Prem prison
that's the main Bangkok prison sometimes
called Bangkok Hilton it's huge it
contains 12 sub-prisons
over 8 000 people crammed in there